Secretary of State Mike Pompeo says the
US could be ready to offer security
assurances to North Korea as part of a
nuclear deal North Korea says it will
dismantle its nuclear test site ahead of
next month's summit between President
Trump and kim jeong-hoon mr. Trump
welcomed that news as a quote very smart
and gracious gesture major Garrett is at
the White House with the latest on this
story major good morning good morning
administration officials fanned out
yesterday to describe a new future for
North Korea one where the nation emerges
from decades of isolation gains
economically from interaction with the
United States and possibly the outside
Western world but these administration
officials emphasize there will be a cost
that will come with that transformation
and they hope they said North Korean
dictator Kim Jong moon is willing to pay
it if we get denuclearization of course
there'll be sanctions relief Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo told Face the
Nation that if North Korea is committed
to destroying its nuclear arsenal we can
create conditions for real economic
prosperity for the North Korean people
punishing economic sanctions would be
lifted and private American investment
could flow into the country you've
talked about making it worth North
Korea's while financially what what
chairman Kim will get from America is
our finest hour entrepreneurs are risk
takers are capital providers ahead of
the president's summit with kim
jeong-hoon next month in Singapore North
Korea announced Saturday that it will
dismantle its nuclear test site in about
ten days destroying its tunnels and
removing its observation and research
facilities nobody believes that this is
easy to do National Security Advisor
John Bolton took a harder line than
Pompeo and said the north still has a
lot to do before sanctions are lifted
they're gonna have to reveal all of
their locations they're gonna have to
allow open inspection Bolton said the
dismantled nuclear weapons would be
flown to a nuclear facility in Oak Ridge
Tennessee where they would be destroyed
once the country's nuclear arsenal has
been removed kim jeong-hoon wants a
commitment from the US
not to invade more than 28,000 American
troops are stationed in South Korea
Pompeyo said that was under
consideration we will have to provide
security assurances to to be sure one
other bit of news the three detainees
held in North Korea who returned the
United States last week were released
yesterday from the hospital here in
Washington and reunited from their
families I can also authoritative ly
report the North Lawn is well mowed and
in great shape behind you they do that
early in the morning let me ask you
about another big thing that happened at
the White House the president
essentially doing a u-turn over this
Chinese company ZTE why is the president
in a tweet talking about saving Chinese
jobs rather than addressing some
long-standing concerns from the US
intelligence community about this
Chinese company it is a curious move by
any standard even a trump standard
because the president's rhetoric as a
candidate and as president has been to
emphasize protecting US jobs not 70,000
jobs in China which is what his tweet
appears to be about now what is ZTE it's
a very large telecom company well the
Commerce Department and Justice
Department recently sanctioned that
company ZTE because it violated US
sanctions by trading with North Korea
and Iran and then lying about it the
Commerce and Justice Department said US
companies could not sell component parts
to z2e
threatening its economic future also to
your point Norah national security
experts United States have cautioned
American consumers not to purchase
phones from ZTE out of national security
concerns now the president's tweet
essentially ordered the Commerce
Department to review these sanctions
even though there's no legal remedy to
do so and the Commerce Department said
it will take a look at it the White
House this morning is trying to clarify
all this saying only that the
president's tweet suggested that
Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross exercises
independent judgment and reach a
conclusion based on the facts and
applicable law Norah major thank you so
much that's another one of these
decisions that has huge implications not
only for our relations with the Chinese
but what they've done in the past
we'll see how it all sort of sorts
itself out that's right the president
said that you know he cares a lot about
trying to trade but he also cares about
North Korea and North Korea being more
important so is that what's at stake
here has he basically decided okay that
other stuff was rhetoric on the campaign
trail but if China is helping us with
North Korea we'll do this for them we'll
see
[Music]